[Música]
este esta melodía que acabamos de
escuchar pertenece a lo que conocemos
como un tonal y un tonal acá en la costa
ecuatoriana es una geometría sonora es
decir es música sacada de una geometría
vamos a ver
nosotros para llegar a este conocimiento
tomamos la cultura huancavilca de
nuestra cultura nativa la heredera de 12
mil años de cultura acá en el litoral
ecuatoriano la música forma parte del
modelo astro biológico del mundo
huancavilca el mismo que representado
por símbolos icónicos geométricos y
numérico partimos con esta hipótesis de
'las desde hace cerca de 25 años atrás
cuando comenzamos las investigaciones
acá y preveíamos de que existía un
elemento más allá de lo que conocemos en
el mundo occidental es decir más allá
del análisis de partituras más allá del
análisis y de los elementos de conceptos
de armonía o de melodía que tienen para
llegar a eso vamos a hacer rápidamente
una síntesis de este razonamiento en el
año de 1605 fueron reducidos le dijeron
a los indígenas de la costa métanse en
unos pueblos porque nos vamos a
las tierras entonces los indígenas de
acá de la costa del sector de la
península decidieron
reducirse en el pueblo de chongón en el
pueblo de chanduy en el pueblo de santa
elena y en el pueblo de colon che esa
fue una decisión de ellos y se redujeron
para los que somos de acá de estas
latitudes esos pueblos los conocemos
porque son pueblos todavía vivos
en el año de 1784 le centaur a la
iglesia les instaura un juicio por hidro
latría a todos estos indígenas porque
ellos continuaban haciendo actos un poco
fuera de la ley y de la religión se dice
que el demonio es adorado por estos
indios normalmente en el campo o en el
cerro cercano al pueblo una vez allí
miren hacia otros cerros como el de
samborondón el opcional o el chimborazo
ya que con ellos se identifica es decir
desde acá del litoral ecuatoriano se
mira hacia los cerros mayores y nosotros
nos preguntábamos por qué fue tan
importante este este elemento para poder
juzgar a ello entonces comenzamos a ver
de que en repetidas ocasiones desde la
desde la parte colonial desde los
momentos
y republicanos siempre se hacía énfasis
acá en la costa ecuatoriana y en todo el
ecuador sobre la visión del chimborazo
entonces en estas últimas fotos vemos
desde guayaquil desde aquí de donde
estamos de cómo se ve el volcán
chimborazo en determinados años acá lo
vemos ya en éste guayaquil moderno
cuando en el año 2012 se nos presentó de
esta manera lo vemos también desde otro
lugar que bodega guayaquil babahoyo y
así lo vamos viendo en repetidas años y
en repetidas partes de la península y de
hecho en nuestro escudo nacional se
encuentra la visión del chimborazo visto
desde acá desde el litoral ecuatoriano
pero porque es importante para nosotros
eso
lo más importante para nuestra cultura
fue nuestro desarrollo agrícola es decir
para poder ser
tener asentamientos y no ser grupos
nómadas necesitábamos saber controlar el
tiempo nosotros decimos amarrar el sol
en el mundo andino se dice la
intihuatana o la piedra que amarra al
sol porque con ellos se forman
calendario un calendario permite la
división espacial del mundo la división
temporal y también sirve para los
pronósticos pronosticar qué es lo que va
a pasar más adelante va a haber lluvia
van a ver las temporadas de agua a la
temporada de sequía entonces esa
síntesis se logra a través de lo que se
conoce como relojes solares el reloj
solar es un útil geométrico que todas
las culturas ancestrales o astro
biológicas del planeta lo han
desarrollado y se desarrolla básicamente
porque cada ciudad o cada cada cultura
está ubicada en una latitud del planeta
y por lo tanto esos relojes solares
tienen distinta geometría esta geometría
que vemos aquí es la que nos corresponde
a nosotros los ecuatorianos porque
estamos
la mitad del mundo si nosotros estamos
en ese punto central hacia el solsticio
de junio desde acá desde guayaquil o
desde cualquier parte del ecuador
siempre habrá una deriva de 23.5 grados
del sol hacia el norte y en el solsticio
de diciembre el 22 de diciembre el sol
pasará al otro lado hacia el sur y en
los equinoccios el 21 de marzo y el 23
de septiembre pasará por encima de
nuestras cabezas se dice ser que ese día
no hay sombra es el día de la no sombra
cuando estamos así ya que en guayaquil
nos gastamos
cuando usted tiene esa figura horizontal
y la gira a 90 grados porque en nuestra
cosmovisión en nuestra como audición lo
que sucede en la tierra sucede en el
cielo y todo lo que sucede en el cielo
sucede en la tierra esto forma lo que
llamamos la estrella solar ecuatorial o
la estrella del sol ecuatorial la famosa
estrella de ocho puntas que la
encontramos en todas las culturas del
ecuador e inclusive en el palacio de la
asamblea nacional no esa figura si
unimos esas aristas nos forma esta otra
figura esta otra figura ya es un
desarrollo propio y local de la cultura
huancavilca porque la cultura
huancavilca en este caso es un sello
precolombino que se encuentra en el
museo de la casa en la cultura es un
sello en donde nos indica pues toda
nuestra cosmogonía en la parte exterior
existen doce elementos que son los doce
meses del año la bóveda celeste con
todas esas estrellitas luego tenemos las
caritas esas caras que se ven en la luna
la luna nueva y la luna llena la luna
la oscura la luna llena es la clara y
luego viene la famosa estrella
huancavilca asentada sobre una silla de
poder de nuestras famosas sillas de
poder un manteños huancavilca esa
cosmogonía que es una síntesis de lo que
nosotros acabamos de ver
nos llevan nos dicen de que al encontrar
la vez de estas pequeñas figuritas de la
cultura valdivia seis mil años atrás
pues ya tenemos una ya tenemos una
referencia de que se está utilizando
esta geometría y estos calendarios
solares desde el posterior las vegas'
esta misma geometría sirve para la
geodesia es decir cuando uno coloca una
estrella solar en un sitio ceremonial
los pueblos se alinean
nuestros pueblos del litoral ecuatoriano
enrumban
y lo que decían
cuando los cuando le sentaré juraron el
juicio se ve claramente de que por
ejemplo colonche que se encuentra el
norte está en línea recta con changüí al
sur y que santa elena que se encuentra
hacia el oeste está en línea recta con
chongón forma una gran cruz geodésica
alineada perfectamente al eje de la
tierra eso lo sabemos ahora obviamente
por por las fotografías satelitales lo
sabemos porque nuestros mapas nuestros
mapas de él y gm el instituto geográfico
militar a sí mismo
y esta es la forma con la tecnología
como los huancavilcas los manteños
huancavilca pudieron viajar hacia el
perú hacia chile y al norte hasta hasta
méxico y es la forma también de cómo
ellos navegaban tierra adentro o se hace
navega en el mar mar afuera y tierra
adentro y la forma de navegar tierra
adentro era colocando estas mismas
geometrías y alineando los pueblos
cuando usted hace hace eso sabe hasta
dónde quiere llegar entonces la mayoría
de nuestros pueblos ancestrales están
alineados
pero no solamente eso cada una de las
comunas de acá del litoral ecuatoriano
cuando usted se acerca a las iglesias y
se para al frente usted se da cuenta de
que a
está en un rumbo y este rumbo pertenece
a la cruz huancavilca es decir nuestras
iglesias en estas comunas que nosotros
las visitamos los fines de semana o en
feriados más comúnmente montañita
valdivia libertador bolívar o lo
manglaralto y nos vamos a bañar y todo
estamos en tierra ancestral alineadas
geodésica mente ajá los músicos
aquí no sé si tuvieron la oportunidad de
ingresar a las exposiciones que tenemos
aquí hay una exposición que se llama
tonal huancavilca y justamente allí se
encuentran estas evidencias de como los
músicos de cómo se atrás se traslada
esta geometría a la música ya los mismos
instrumentos estos instrumentos por
ejemplo que están exhibidos ahí estos
músicos tienen unos instrumentos de
viento han taras les llaman aqui en peru
zampoñas cicus songs ampollas o flautas
de pan le dicen en europa pero tienen
esta forma particular que
son una cruz huancavilca de siete notas
siete tubos
siete elementos
este este músico con el cual
representamos todas estas como ponía
tiene este instrumento de siete notas
como llegan ellos a estas siete notas
nuevamente pasamos de esa geometría a un
reticulado es decir cuando cuando
nosotros comenzamos a unir cada uno de
estos puntos entre sí a tirar hilos como
llaman en las comunas tejedoras vamos a
aislar vamos a amarrar una vez que uno
hace en la madre
y forma este reticulado nosotros vemos
de que se crean muchas cosas una de las
cosas son los instrumentos musicales los
instrumentos musicales tanto los
antiguos como los contemporáneos tienen
que tener una forma y un reticulado que
les dé sentido el sentido que tienen los
instrumentos musicales cuando un luthier
los crea es el sentido que va más allá
del simple hecho estético va en el
sentido de la comunión con una tradición
con una geometría con un espíritu con
una cultura como llaman en europa común
tu gente
con una o con un espíritu que debe estar
en el interior del instrumento ese
instrumento que ustedes están viendo ahí
que no es otra cosa que el diseño del
instrumento que está exhibido acá es
decir las marín wash
que se tocan en escenarios nacionales e
internacionales este este diseño que
también se basa en el reticulado de
nuestra cultura huancavilca da lugar a
estas guitarras con las que hemos estado
tocando en todo el mundo en en china a
alemania a seúl
qatar a en todas las partes porque lo
digo porque básicamente nuestra
geometría porque básicamente los
conceptos de nuestra cultura
si tienen o tienden hacia la
globalización de lo humano
esta guitarra arpa sacada de la
proporción 41 de la de nuestra cultura
huancavilca que es la que tenemos
exhibida y con la que hemos dado
innumerables conciertos la guitarra
triple mástil la huma como le
llamamos nosotros también es una
guitarra que se ha paseado por todas
partes y básicamente obedece a esta
geometría y la del último diseño este
diseño de la guitarra la valquiria es un
diseño en el cual nosotros lo estamos
desarrollando ya para su reproducción a
nivel industrial
y puedes tener obviamente ya una una
reproducción en masa no en las mismas
comunas porque eso es lo importante de
que esté laminado de bambú o de guadua
se está realizando en las comunas de dos
mangas de allá de de santa elena
la geometría musical ok
cuando nosotros revisamos revisamos este
este elemento de la cruz huancavilca nos
damos cuenta de que existen unas
relaciones místicas es decir de que al
interior de las comunas no solamente es
el diseño sino que ese diseño está
relacionado con todo un universo de
cosmogonía está relacionado con los
distintos momentos y con los distintos
colores con los distintos animales y con
los distintos espíritus que existen en
todas estas comunas y forma una rueda
armónica en la cual los blogs los
antiguos la gente que vive allá en el
libertador bolívar que vive en holón que
viven manglaralto e interpretan de una
manera distinta y lo vemos tocando un
violín por ese violín no tiene nada que
ver con occidental lo afinan de una
manera distinta lo hacen sonar de una
manera distinta el repertorio es
totalmente distinto forman esta cruz o
esta geometría de colorimetría que
responde justamente a esta escultura yo
quiero en este momento mostrarles como
suena
a huancavilca una geometría sonora
huancavilca y quiero pedirle a la
artista artista y luthier músico y
luthier ángela sanbrano para que me
acompañe para interpretar esta geometría
sonora
total
[Música]
[Aplausos]